creusez fouillé dépoussiérer sur le
chantier de 8 sur loire les archéologues
se penche sur des vestiges du
paléolithique
on est ici parce que lors des fouilles
qui s'intéressait au néolithique ils ont
trouvé des vestiges plus ancien des
concentrations de silex un foyer et donc
notre objectif c'était de mieux
caractériser ces vestiges pour
comprendre ce qu'on fait les hommes il y
a dix mille ans
ces fouilles ont une particularité elles
sont labellisés archéo éthiques
ce label créé par l'association du même
nom vise à réduire les discriminations
lors des recherches et se bat contre le
sexisme encore présents dans
l'archéologie
alors finalement ce label ne change pas
tellement notre façon de faire puisque
ça reprend des valeurs qu'on défend
depuis longtemps mais c'est un moyen de
les mettre en lumière tous les membres
de l'équipe ont adhéré à une charte de
bonne conduite pour certaines étudiantes
ce label était un critère de sélection
pour les stages d'été
déjà que ce soit une femme comme celle
de stage et en plus un gentil que ça m'a
rassuré pour ma première expérience
disons je trouve ça vraiment bien
justement ce internet prévenir un petit
peu le pas tout ce qui est
une stimulation et je trouve ça super
intéressant et important de le faire
parce que le monde de l'art corrigeant
lui même à ses parents drame et en
promettant des fois ça peut être
compliqué et justement je trouve ça
important de défendre ses idées le
chantier prendra fin la semaine
prochaine d'ici là l'équipe espère
encore trouver quelques silex et
vestiges pour comprendre un peu mieux le
quotidien des hommes du paléolithique